I'm Katie Kraus and James Graham is here
he won the for last night so excited to
have you here thank you so much for
having me now that you've had some time
to kind of process this major when how
are you feeling still in shock because
obviously like everyone goes into these
things with a certain mindset like I was
gonna do my best and I see what happens
and like obviously everyone who enters
these things things they've got a chance
of winning but I didn't actually think
I'd win so I was like what you really
didn't know genuinely like when I was on
stage me and Sharia I been practicing my
gracious loser face and everything yeah
I was like but like when when did he
said my name it was like wow yeah sure
like yeah so shocked I wasn't really
that shocked though because you
performed so well last night and I want
to bring up the Adele hello performance
because I've already been telling you
how amazing it was we actually have a
clip of it that I want to play but what
I love are your parents in this clip
because they genuinely look so yeah
there's a face who's that yeah yeah he
looked just mesmerized so I want you
guys to take a look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the best in your face watching yeah I
did the faces that I do when I'm singing
I don't like watching myself
how'd you watch that back yet yeah I had
watched a couple of times just to sort
of see if I did okay what did your
parents say when you won well me and my
mom and dad and my brother I got an
older brother we are like a family of
talkers we talk a lot and I got
backstage after the announcement and me
my mom and dad sat down and we like no
one spoke we're just like because of the
shark yeah just like my mom lets me it
was like I was like it's just correct I
think we're all in shock because we've
been they've sacrificed so much for me
as well like my mum's quit jobs had no
job at times just to be around ready in
case I needed to drive me somewhere like
before I drove like when I was a little
quite a bit younger yeah so this is like
this is like a win for there for us it's
for me my mum and dad and my brother
it's not just for me like winning it is
for me and my entire family and all my
friends and anyone who's been there
along the journey with me so it's just
it's crazy who's so crazy
I think what people don't realize is
that this wasn't really an overnight
success story for you though like you
have kind of been putting in the work
you've been doing for so long so what
does that feel like to finally have that
moment just like amazing because yeah
I've been working at this for like I've
been in the music industry if you like
for maybe like six six years yeah and
you're only 21 I'm only 21 yeah so I've
been doing it since I was quite bit
younger but I've been going at it for a
while
and I pretty much I mean there's not
been there's been a lot of knows there's
been a lot of nearly 'z there's never
been like a okay yeah this is something
that's actually gonna now transfer you
to step up a level and have a chance to
do this this and this like making an
album signed to a label so even talking
about it it's just crazy do you feel
like all those knows now where you're
like happy that they were knows because
this is the happy outcome was yeah I
just feel like they must have been meant
your life was meant to be yeah I guess
but like I literally have not a lot to
say about it I'm saying I'm so in shock
about everything all I can say is just
keep saying the word incredible and
shocked because um it's
if you guys are just now tuning in make
sure you send in all your fan questions
we are live right now I do want to play
another clip for you because Sarah
Hyland is a big fan of yours I saw last
night haven't seen this video yeah you
did yeah we want to play for you guys
Sarah Hyland literally loves James just
as much as we do so take a look oh my
god I look like a disaster right now but
oh my god James grab one before he one
before I called it even though Shohreh
oj Baba she had a queen no did you have
you talked to Sarah yeah I did I said
like thank you for loving and stuff and
she was on now Congrats you did amazing
and she's great she's like she's like
every supporter which is incredible yeah
any other celebrity supporters I'm
curious if Adele watched your
performance
no I'm saying this in every interview
today we need to make this happen
because she needs to see it hope you
like it and I need to do a duet with her
that needs to happen it does need to
happen I mean the video already has so
many views I'm curious if she's been one
of them maybe you my fellow Brit let's
do this yeah so any other celebrities
that have reached out obviously Khaled
has some famous friends studious and
famous friends yeah there's some there's
some some some random people like
looking at my stories and we're tweeting
about the show I think on one of the
week sort of show Justin Timberlake
tweeted about a show Jamie Foxx tweeted
about about something about what was
something did I sing he tweeted about
and when I sang a song for you the very
first week as well they like everything
about this show is crazy like that's the
thing with this show it's so like
exclusive it feels so exclusive because
the other shows I feel like it's better
and avoids there they're quite they're
like talent shows and they're amazing
but they like talent shows for me this
is like a label showcase but televised
so it's really music industry rather
than TV industry in it that's why I love
it so much well and I feel like the
judges really do continue working with
you after the fact and they say really
all these resources right yeah I mean
the finals just just been and gone and
I've been on face
time with Megan and I saw I've met with
Diddy already and the labels already
rolling and Megan's FaceTime me like
again and again and just saying
different things about ideas there might
be a duet we could do all sorts of
things that's crazy
do you have their numbers in your phone
I do yes so can we FaceTime one of them
can we see if they answer we could try
she would I for Megan I think we should
go we should go for Megan we should go
for any of them they're all fabulous is
she gonna be shocked she'll probably be
like what's going on we I love Megan
Trainor guys this is happening we're
live right now with James and we're
attempting to FaceTime Megan Trainor
that we he is what day is it today it's
Friday is she answering we have an
answer good what what do you do did you
just do my accent to me Megan you're
live on Entertainment Tonight
Simon tonight continue yeah this thing
was so bad I just wanted to say hi and
everyone here at entertainments and I
wanted to say hi
we're so proud of him can she hear us oh
okay oh cool I'll call you later I'll
call you back bye I love you oh boy oh
my god okay so you really you really do
have a direct connection she just
answered your FaceTime and she wants to
do it with you I really do it Megan as
well I really connect to a Megan from
the start she was like a big supporter
of mine through the whole thing and
she's she's amazing I really it was like
a sort of a sudden click with her just
really connected with her story and
she's been amazing like she she's always
there on the end of the phone and she's
great I love hearing stories like that
you have a ton of questions coming in so
we're actually going to take some of
these Lily Mendes over on YouTube says
what is the meaning of your necklace
that you always wear this is my Saint
Christopher and my mum and dad brought
me this on the back ed she says 21st
love mum and dad they engraved it
my 21st birthday so recently but I used
to have another one but I lost it for my
team but and it's like a Saint
Christopher paints a a travel and they
were saying that hopefully my music will
take me you know to amazing places and
this will we're always keep me safe
sentimental Lauren says are you planning
on releasing some merch any time in the
future I haven't actually thought about
that but yeah definitely that's a really
good idea that is a good idea yeah okay
yeah definitely just yeah you gotta
start thinking about yeah I know my
head's just still like a big blur of
everything right now last time I talked
to you is right before you hit the stage
for finale night you said that you were
gonna celebrate big you were hoping to
take some Jager shots maybe how did you
celebrate pretty much just doing that to
be honest like there was a like a little
rap party for the show yeah we just had
some drinks and celebrated because like
it becomes like a big family share
everyone on the show like I love I love
them all I love everyone from the people
who just look after us day-to-day so the
stage managers to the mic guys so the
camera like they're all so cool and so
great and you generally become friends
of everyone so it was really nice to
just pie up with him a little bit last
night who gets the rowdiest between DJ
Khaled and Diddy
I feel like did he's like very contained
Lions too cool he's so cool he could be
like so drunk and you wouldn't even know
he do play do that he always just looked
so collected he's like superhuman
yeah yeah he's just in every way like
career-wise personality-wise everything
about him is just he's like a superhero
what's the craziest thing that he made
you do throughout this process to really
make you a winner because we've seen him
in the past when he did making a band
and he made those girls do something
like he wanted them to fight for it
craziest thing he made me do well I mean
not that he made me do it he really did
help me pull out my emotion like he
unlocked that how by just drilling and
drilling and drilling and saying you
know I'm doing it and being harsh like
being really harsh but like in a in a
good way obviously but he was just like
you're not doing
I need to get a feeling I'm not getting
feeling and that him keeping pushing on
that and keep pressing those buttons
yeah snaps it out of me and now I got it
did he ever make you cry no are you sure
yeah okay
only well I didn't cry before this show
ever ever I just don't cry it's not my
thing
but quite a few times through this show
like in rehearsals or after shows never
in rehearsal was just like during shows
when I sung fix you in the finale I
cried at the end yeah it's an emotional
song there was like the last song yeah
it was just the whole thing but ya know
I tend not to cry too much too tough for
that Lily from YouTube says James you
are so talented in your voice always
moves me a lot of congratulations are
coming in Railly says what was the
experience like the first time that you
performed on the forest stage very scary
it was scary when I saw that I sung I
can't make you love me as a third song
just to sort of an introduction thing
that didn't get properly televised just
as like an intro and I remember walking
out the doors and the crowds all around
you like a Coliseum and then judges are
really a lot closer than than it looks
yeah a lot close like four steps down
and you're right there oh geez
so it's definitely intimidating but you
know it was amazing everything about the
show has been incredible looking ahead
to the future and obviously you have
such an insane vocal range where do you
see your place in the music industry I
would like to think that what I want to
do I want to bring back some of the
old-school like soul R&B we've got
elements of pop obviously but I want to
bring back that old-school feeling to
music and like the fact that I'm only 21
yeah I think is quite cool thing like
the way a dress and stuff you wouldn't
necessarily think I'm gonna come out and
sing that type of music like singing
Adele hello and all that kind of thing
but I wanna I want to try and be like
slightly different with different
elements but male Adele I think you can
do it
I'm gonna try my very best I mean it's a
big she's I mean because they're yeah
amazing I'm gonna try I'm gonna try and
climb up to where you already you might
have to fight off Sam Smith that's one
for the challenge he's great I'm often
challenged I know that you get a lot of
comparisons to Shawn Mendes of course
how do you feel about that amazing Shawn
is is incredible in it he's he's like
whole rise up to where he is now
like really inspires me because he was
on doing Spotify a lot of Spotify stuff
and then he just exploded and he's he's
such a nice guy
and so talented so for me that just
gives me like it really inspires me
because it shows that he's like that
talent can you know if you've got
something and you push it right it can
work like he's living proof that talent
can shine through have you met him I
haven't met him I've spoken to him a
couple of times on Twitter he reached
out to me a couple of years ago we were
just talking in general but he's a he's
amazing amazing he reached out because
of X Factor yeah it was way back then oh
no way yeah like giving advice or worse
yeah he was just like hey buddy your
falsettos amazing really appreciated it
and we just spoke us all you're
incredible you're killing it amazing
just a few different things I mean you
say it so casually that's amazing it is
amazing yeah I try and stay really cool
but I actually freaked out inside who if
you could collaborate with any artist
what do you see yourself doing that with
are you thinking about that yeah I'd you
know I I change like every day who but
today I'm on Adele I would love to do do
it like a collab with Adele we need some
new Adele music anyways you can
immediately happen I could be involved
in it that we good yes aware of Adele
will be like I don't think she's I
actually don't think no well we'll try
and make it happen so if anyone can make
it happen you're really pulling for this
I'm gonna badger I'm just gonna like
keep hello hello talk to our people
hello literally hello hello um maybe you
can start off the song how you started
it off last night and she'll be like
like it's guys guys cool yeah what are
you thinking for album plans like is
that in the back of your mind right now
yeah I am I have some some ideas I
actually have this whole idea of how I
would do an album and a certain thing
that I'm not going to say but a certain
thing that I would do with my album that
would tie in it would tie in as like a
whole package that's what I'm saying I
know I know I mean in my head like a
visual album maybe something like that
yeah sonically what would it sound like
it would be also would it be all those
slow songs would you have some upbeat
like pop rock infusion in there yeah
definitely I want to do like the R&B
soul slowed back like a devil maybe type
ballads but with more R&B or soul in but
then I like I want to do some more tempo
with some like funk fusion we've just at
the pop and the soul so I've got my own
idea of some certain things so maybe
like bringing back some James Brown
elements to music stuff like that
Michael Jackson all what old-school
influence is all I was go influences but
I've got a lot a lot of ideas actually
just need to sit down with a few people
like Diddy yeah I've got a lot of stuff
we've got a lot of stuff to talk about
when does that process officially start
so I fly back to the UK tomorrow to have
some rest for a week or two which is
really needed on the show but then I'm
back and I'm straight to work okay so
right away right away when can we expect
a single I don't know I mean I guess it
just depends when we get the single when
we get it right as in when it all clicks
and comes together so that could be in
three months could be in six months
could be in a year but I'm not gonna
rush anything I really don't want to
rush anything because this first release
needs to be perfect like I want this
album to be you one of those albums we
listen to and every songs like I hear
yeah you're gonna put the work in really
poking you let's talk about the fans a
little bit because your social media has
just exploded any memorable fan
experiences yet are people recognizing
you on the street yeah there's been a
few there's been a few things actually
was a
Westfield's with Whitney the week
leading up to the to the finale and we
were walk she walked off summer I don't
know why she wasn't I was a standing
wave her and this group of maybe like
six or seven girls walked past and one
of them recognized me but she literally
was oh right my face and then was not oh
my god and they were like going crazy
one of them was like I love you and she
threw her phone at me she's just oh my
gosh you gave her back oh yeah I didn't
take it I should have done but yeah did
you take a selfie oh yeah I took a
selfie think I'm a tweet wrote that she
threw at me sounds crazy how are you
handling all the attention I think I I
stay like my mind stays pretty calm and
stuff just generally that's just how I
am
it's very overwhelming especially it's
like when things I was getting
recognized like over here I'm like
alright so I'm from a village in England
Oh like it's small a small village now I
moved out of London so small village and
I'm over here in America and people know
who I am it's just really overwhelming
and it was always gonna be I was a bit
nervous coming on the show being English
and the only the only English person on
the whole show because we are in America
obviously and I wasn't sure whether the
public would be like go home but the
love has been incredible so I love I
love everyone you know for everyone out
there wondering we do have to ask you
are you single what are you looking for
I am single what am I looking for I mean
I'm just looking for I'm focused on
music right now guys so now looking for
anything not looking for any sort of
girlfriend or anything right now I'm
focused on my music my music is my
girlfriend okay that's a good way to put
it yeah we're gonna take a few more
questions
oh just a lot of Congrats Oh
charreah J we do need to ask about that
friendship yes
how was she afterwards and are you guys
obviously still friends yeah yeah she
was she was great afterwards and that
girl is 100% she's like stuck with me
for life now I love her she held me
this process a lot as well because
there's certain times when you question
yourself or your sister a song and you
get stressed she's been doing this for
so long such a pro already that she was
just like she helped me through most of
the weeks to be honest and her story is
so inspiring and so beautiful and I mean
I teared up a little bit last night when
we heard that her cancer was gone like
that's a mate I know that was so
beautiful I love her I really really
love her she's incredible and you called
her the love of your life she's the she
is my she's my soul mate any chance that
we could see a collaboration with you
two already spoken to her people her
people have spoken to my people I've
spoken to her she's spoken to me we're
definitely 107 I can't say right now on
camera we're 100% gonna be doing a
collaboration I feel like that makes
Diddy happy too probably yeah definitely
but not I mean I'm looking for today is
gonna be good she's uh she's already
sent me a few ideas yeah okay are you
gonna be before we're gonna wrap up soon
but before we let you go are you gonna
be writing your own music do you think
yeah so my last maybe like three years
before doing the show I actually spent
as a songwriter so I that's all I was
doing I didn't do one live performance
for three years before my first
performance on the show oh wow yeah so I
was a bit out of practice but I was just
a writer for different things I did a
couple of things with the writing team
for Empire that's just what I was doing
really for three years just a writer in
a den writing for other people what
inspires you like where do you find
everything everything inspires me I like
to write in different ways because to be
honest like I've never really had my
heart broken by like a girl or that sort
of situation have you broken any hearts
I hope not okay but I just like like
sometimes I watch I watch like a movie
and I'll write a song from the point of
one of the characters in the movie just
different things like different little
tricks that I learnt from people that I
worked with over the years yeah any
messages to your fans like do you have a
thing do you want to say thank you them
I'd love to say thank yous them guys so
I love you all so much I say amazing
around all the time I was feeling
everything I write on me is a bad move I
love you all love but I really do love
you all you've helped me through this
crazy journey and for all of like my new
fans that have come on board since the
for I love all of you and I appreciate
all of you for all of my fans who've
been there since I did like x-factor I
love all of you and this is just the
beginning I promise we're gonna we're
gonna rise to the top I promise so thank
you so much for being here so much for
having me and thank you guys for
watching and really appreciate it you
can keep up with James on all the social
media Instagram Twitter and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you